hello folks welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics at
all uh everybody else does mathematics
what is mathematics it's the movement of
Concepts that's what everybody does why
because they never Define what an object
is essentially anyways it's uh pretty
cold here in Germany and I think it's
about 2 or three
degrees uh the other day was like five
below zero so yeah I'm uh I'm well uh
Dressed overdressed maybe and uh someone
asked you know maybe I should just turn
the heater on or whatever I stopped
using a heater a couple uh two or three
years ago uh partly because of you know
waste of money but um partly because of
Health it's an issue that I think uh uh
I don't need it you know I'd rather
cover up and it also gives me an
incentive to uh you do some gym you know
otherwise uh you know just stay here and
and just uh freeze to death anyways we
got a great day today I'm going to skip
the extinction segment today because we
got uh quite a bit of material today
lots of questions especially from
mathematicians or mathematically
inclined or people who think they know
something about physics and think that
math has something to do with physics
uhuh and yeah we have a name for them
and uh so let's start there and then
well by the way later on I'll continue
with the uh with the main course today
which is you know the um time travel can
be time travel okay so let's begin with
our uh segment here with the questions
and comments that people made since last
time and the way I'm going to begin
today I'm going to start by defining an
important word that we're going to need
today and it's this word idiot you know
ideot idiot ideot you can pronounce it
any way you want um it's an individual
Big Ideas you know we call them ideats
or idiots right come from the uh ancient
Kling on you know meaning big idea you
know you have little ideas just so just
ideas then you have idea right big ideas
and some of these people uh just about
all of them think that math has
something to do with physics
okay and uh I think we're going to set
them straight today okay yeah no uh math
has nothing at all to do with physics in
physics we do not use math okay at all
numbers equations we don't use any of
that okay not in physics okay now maybe
they use it somewhere else certainly not
in physics and that's what we're going
to show today so we have our first uh
candidate here visitor he says math is
not the language of science but yes it
is the language of
physics okay uh where have you been for
the past uh few hundred years you can
make physics what it isn't you can't
make physics what it isn't what you're
looking for is natural philosophy
uh yeah in the 17th century they used to
call this uh so-called science they
called it natural philosophy what did
that mean well it meant that um you know
they were doing they were trying to
figure out how this universe works that
gradually uh evolved
into uh experiments and equations you
know measurement and equations and uh
the question is uh whether experiments
measurements and equations have anything
at all to do with physics okay that's
the question and so the first thing we
need to realize here is that this fell
did not Define physics so we don't know
what he's talking about until he defines
physics we won't know that what he says
there is true you know or that it's
rational or that it's consistent with
whatever what everybody understands for
physics okay and by everybody I mean
everybody except the mathematicians out
there okay so he forgot to Define
physics Aristotle defined physics he's a
guy who invented this word that's where
we got the word from and he didn't
Define it as it's defined today so
that's the first thing you should know
the fact that the mathematicians changed
the definition last 400 years doesn't
mean that we can't change it again okay
we can change definitions what if we
find that they are irrational okay the
ones that these people are using okay in
science we don't care what the
mathematicians call physics physics or
whether they all agree if it's
irrational science rejects their claim
so yeah you can't use Authority here and
say oh all the mathematicians on Earth
voted for the definition of physics
that's what they do that's what they
call physics we don't care science
doesn't care
okay uh science physics is whatever uh
rational definition of the word physics
says it is okay and you don't have to
like the definitions all you have to do
is propose one that is more rational you
know like a better mouse
trap otherwise you have to keep your
trap shut because you have nothing to
offer science okay and this guy says
also 99% of humanity doesn't know what
the difference between description and
explanation I don't think he knows
either but you know how do you explain
with math he's insisting on math how do
you explain with math so if if um if
physics is about
explaining and this guy says that we use
math in physics then the question is you
know how do you how do you explain with
math that's all he's got to do explain
that okay another fellow
say uh science and physics is about
understanding nature and universe uhuh
understanding you know here means
explanation of causes and mechanisms
that's what an explanation is not
mathema AAL descriptions so he continues
he says in science engineering and
physics we use mathematical
representations to help describe and
explain absolutely not okay math has no
power to explain anything okay math can
only describe
quantitatively and in science phys the
question then is is physics about
explaining or is physics about
describing okay and one of the problems
there that we have have some people have
out there uh what do they call them um
idiots idiots okay and what do they say
they say that uh an explanation it's
just a bunch of descriptions a listing
of descriptions we're going to debunk
that today and by debunk I don't mean
we're going to convince you and persuade
you to believe that's not what we're
here for belief belongs in religion
debunking here is in a different context
debunking means we Define terms and then
using those definitions we use them
consistently and we show that logically
something fails a theory or whatever
okay now you don't have to read to those
definitions but again that means you
have to propose a better mouse trap or
keep your trap shut okay because you
don't know you don't have anything to
contribute to
science okay uh here we have um
mathematic mathematics yeah is correct
probably it's just the description of
the universe just as the menu is not the
dinner uh you cannot eat the menu okay
mathematics is not reality just a
description of reality if mathematics
and logic are the only things that
enable you to describe the universe what
guarantees do you you what guarantees
you that there is a deeper
infrastructure than the mathematical
description well the first thing is you
know uh what does uh this uh description
have to do with physics but this you
know unless you Define physics tell me
what the definition of the word physics
means you know all that is worthless
nonsense you haven't said anything
because you haven't defined physics H
and then what is this nonsense about
deeper
infrastructure what do they use these
these people are not even in the
ballpark they don't they don't even know
what questions that they don't know what
they're supposed to be investigating
researching what they're supposed to
come up with theories for okay okay and
so a rational individual seeks an
explanation that's I guess the deeper
infrastructure that he's talking about
okay the underlying causes mechanisms of
gravity electromagnetism atom you know
the workings of the atom Etc that's what
a rational individual wants to
understand now people who do math they
don't care about any of that and that's
why they don't understand even what the
questions are so when someone says you
know uh what does this pencil fall to
the floor you
know does it fall to the ceiling and
they don't understand the question why
are you asking that you know it's it
never occurred to them to ask that
question you know why do things fall to
the floor you know and so this is where
the problem is this is where it starts
and where it ends okay because these
people are thinking in other terms they
they have other garbage in their little
tiny brains you know ant brains okay so
here's another fell it says math may be
a language but it's also a form of proof
proof what proof got to do with anything
proof belongs to religion proof means
they convince you of something yet now
you have been recruited that's what
proof means okay what is proof to you is
a lie to the guy across the street he
has a different proof you know that goes
completely against what your proof is
you know some people think it's uh
SpaceTime uh began uh with big bang and
other people believe that God made the
whole universe so there's different
proofs out there for different people we
don't use proof in science you should
know that by now unless you studied at
the what Cambridge Monastery or the uh
what is it the Harvard U Cathedral you
know maybe you studi Divinity studies or
something like that I suppose you could
say physics is more uh about
data what are these people thinking of
these people have no clue what they're
even talking about okay
uh then it is about properties of a
thing or action uhhuh regardless of all
of them require math to confirm or deny
I guess he's talking about opinion you
know what poer said was what
falsifiability maybe that's what he's
got going through his tiny brain I mean
all these mathematicians they have no
clue whatsoever what the what the issues
are they're not even on on the same page
they're not even in the same planet or
in the same universe I mean who knows
where they are and uh here's a last one
says uh seems to me normal human
language is insufficient to describe
phenomena with Precision we don't
describe and what does precision have
anything to do with anything we don't
use Precision in physics what I mean
this is as precise as it gets you know
you let go of the pencil and it doesn't
go below below the in this case the
table but it doesn't go below the floor
for some reason you know it doesn't
crash through the floor and go all the
way to the center of the earth that's as
precise as it gets when you know the
pencil hits the floor that's very
precise okay if you need High Precision
what else is there if not math well we
don't need uh High Precision we don't
need Precision at all Precision has
nothing to do with physics okay so let's
get it right uh so yeah again neither
Precision or accuracy have anything to
do with physics and you're not even the
ballpark uh says if m is not the
language of physics then what is English
German Chinese well you can use any
language uh really to express physics
okay because as long as you stay
qualitatively you know you explain a
mechanism a cause you're okay we won't
hurt you you know this is how how we do
justice here we we use the uh uh dough
roller or good old Excalibur there we
stab you with it
okay so uh yeah you can use any language
okay but uh um make sure it's
qualitative instead of quantitative then
we have there the definition expl what
is physics explanation of causes and
mechanisms got it we need an explanation
of causes and mechanism we want to know
why what causes this pencil to fall
always downwards never to the ceiling
what causes the moon to be so faithful
to the Earth instead of flying out of
the solar system same for the Earth
flying out of the solar system you know
away from the Sun what keeps it what
prevents the electron the electron bead
from flying outside you know the atom
that's what we want to understand okay
and so we need a mechanism a physical
mechanism not one using Concepts again
Concepts black magic okay we don't use
con we don't move them around you have
to put a physical entity there okay
let's make sure we understand that
therefore the language of physics is ill
illustration anyone who
cannot make a uh movie of his mechanism
mechanism you know what a mechanism is
like you know how a car works if you
cannot make a movie of that you're not a
physicist okay so you should be able to
make a movie of any mechanism you
propose because mechanism hopefully
involve objects not abstract Concepts
okay so we're talking about mechanisms
we're talking about causes and we're
saying that the the language of physics
is illustration not math what do we use
math for math is only going to quantify
something it's going to give us a
measurement you're going to put it in
equation say well this is how this is
the description of its motion so to
speak yeah that's like saying you can
describe a chair a chair has four legs
mathematically right four legs one back
crust uh one seed and maybe two armrests
great I described it mathematically and
is that physics is that
science okay so this is the issue no we
have no use for accuracy or for
descriptions in physics we explain in
physic what do we explain causes and
mechanism so we have to go a little step
backwards uh for these slope uh folks
slow slow folks slow folks um what
because they never learned anything in
college or in high school wherever they
went you know they went to these
monasteries I get get these phds and
what Divinity studies or whatever and uh
they never learned what explanations are
what descriptions are and what the
differences are so let's go into that
what is the difference between a
description and an explanation okay here
we go with the first one
okay uh these are the proposed
definitions in science you don't have to
agree to them you just if you don't if
you don't we don't agree by the way in
science we don't even agree to disagree
there's no such thing as agreement in
science that's religion again in science
we don't agree what we do is we Define
and we defend our definitions you don't
like the definition no problem you
propose a better mouse trrap or keep
your mouse straap
shut okay the scripture listing of the
properties of an object image or scene
you have a static image static object
static image or or scene and you're
going to describe it what are you going
to use you're going to use primarily
adjectives okay that's how you describe
because it's a static scene nothing's
moving you should not be using verbs or
adverbs I can't imagine using that but
maybe there's some situation where it
does but in general you're going to be
using adjectives okay because you're
going to be describing images that are
on in front of the person's ey eyes now
what's objective is what comes out of
the screen okay that's objective for all
of us now everybody interprets maybe
something different from the screen
that's subjective okay but objective is
what comes out of the screen that's what
we call objective okay okay and it
doesn't mean that you know you said well
I saw it green the other guy said I saw
it red well that's again that's
subjective okay uh narrative we like
that word narrative or narra narration
description of motion okay because there
are descriptions where you don't have a
fixed static screen you have uh so so to
speak a film strip a movie right and uh
using a
chronological uh way right so if you
tell a little story or something that
happened well just objectively right you
go step by step and you say this is what
happened first this is what happened
second this is what happened third
without giving your opinion without
giving you a theory you just say look
this is what I saw objectively okay and
that's called a narrative or a
narration um explanation something
totally different explanation physical
interpretation of causes and mechanisms
underlying a phenomena that's what it is
for physics in philosophy explanation
which is the other branch of science by
the way interpretation of the reasons
and purposes behind an action okay why
did someone do something okay and we're
going to see a couple examples today
explanation answers why questions
whereas description usually answers how
questions okay uh when they're Nar Nar
narration narratives or
narrations uh explanation answers why
questions and synonyms physical
interpretation Theory okay so when every
time you say fruit Theory you're not
talking about description mathematical
or otherwise you are talking about an uh
an explanation
okay okay so here we have a couple
examples maybe we can illustrate what I
just said okay so that we can uh you
know all zero in on the same notion that
we're trying to convey here today here
we have a car crash okay and so the cop
says uh what happened the girl goes out
blah blah blah blah blah it says and the
red car struck the blue
car well that's not a description it's
already an explanation it's already a
them
Theory she's giving her opinion of how
it happened and not not only an opinion
she's giving you an explanation a theory
what she thinks happened okay and so
yeah the cops just just wants the facts
and she's not giving him the facts she's
already interpreting okay no she should
say look two cars crashed or the blue
and the red car crashed or they bumped
each other that's a description okay
you're just not giving any opinion no
Theory you're just a crashed okay the
theory you know that's for the you know
lawyers for the U for the insurance
companies you know the red car says uh
yeah this guy I mean the blue car says
the the red car crashed into me and the
insurance guys on the red car say no no
no the blue car backed up and hit me
from from the front and then uh two
others come in there and they have
different theories they say look there
was a chain underneath the blue car and
then pulled it backwards and hit the red
car and the other guy said oh there was
a chain tied to the red car to a truck
and the truck moved forward and hit the
blue car and they have all these
theories okay those are theories those
are explanations of what people think
happened okay that's the issue but uh
objectively you have to say two cars
crashed that's a
description explanation is when you say
what she said the blue car or the red
car hit the blue car then you're then
you're giving a theory okay okay let's
look at another one here uh probably a
little more uh closer to the land of
physics really it's from religion but
it's a it's a physical interpretation
okay here it is we have God okay and
here's our Universal movie what's a
universal movie well that's our tool
that when we use where everything within
a single frame is um um static in other
words everything within a single frame
all we have there is location
objects uh distance between the atoms in
the universe everything in the universe
is a is in a single frame there every
object in the universe okay and uh yeah
we propose that uh matter is finite in
the sense that it's
countable in other words uh there's not
an infinite number of atoms in the
universe okay there can't be um but
that's the assumption that we start with
here here anyways the point here is that
God uh has nothing in that first frame
on the left and then on the second frame
the one in the middle suddenly we have
the Earth what what they call the world
right and uh we have Adam and Eve so he
created that maybe maybe in seven days I
show it only in one day but uh he was
creating one thing at a time and that
means that from zero suddenly we went to
something okay from nothing to
something okay that's the religion
version at least from uh Christianity
okay and um here's the version from
so-called science mathematical physics
meaning uh what do we call that religion
it's not even religion it's irrational
so it's not even religion religion uh
has a upper hand a traditional religion
like Christianity or uh Islam Etc they
have a little Edge over mathematical
physics because at least they deal with
what seem to be objects you know they
talk about God and they're thinking
about this magician human-like magician
they say it's he looks like us or we
look like him right and so we M or less
get more or less get the idea at least
that the objects are there now we have
to explain how that magician made
something from nothing that's another
issue but in the case of Quant of uh
general relativity which is the one that
talks about the creation of our universe
you know we got a problem because we got
this situation here we have nothing in
the first frame and suddenly we have
this Singularity a little dot I put it
as a white dot in frame number two and
eventually in frame gazillion over there
you know you have uh our universe today
right uh what they paint as a you know
the W map uh thingy okay so the question
is we're going to look at frame number
one and number two those are the ones
we're interested in and the problem
there is they always start a frame start
at frame number two they say look The
Singularity and suddenly it exploded and
blah blah blah okay great how did the
singularity get there how did we go from
frame one where there's nothing to the
singularity where there's something or
was a singularity there for eternity and
suddenly for whatever reason it decided
to explode so uh and the way they answer
that is they say well it's an
unscientific question because we have no
way of proving uh the hypothesis the
theory what came before The Singularity
or how it got there yeah yeah that's
that's the only thing you had to explain
I mean they they have this nonsense
where you know they take the real back
uh they say all the galaxies were closer
together yesterday and closer even
closer the day before and so they take
the the tape all the way to square one
and they say uh really frame two and
they say okay all this was crunch into a
singularity yeah we want to know how the
singularity got there I mean if you
can't answer answer that your theory is
bunk it's garbage I mean that's the only
question you got to answer how the
singularity got there that's the only
one we're interested the rest is
nonsense and to say it's unscientific
it's just skirting the question okay so
here's uh another uh issue here here
we're going to show a uh an explanation
I guess let's find out if it is okay we
have this we have uh a motor an engine
right and uh car engine and talks about
the oil how it goes through there and so
it says first sentence there says motor
oil is used to lubricate moving Parts
clean prevent corrosion etc etc right
then that second one oil galleries we
are channels that carry oil to various
engine parts then the next one says the
oil filter removes unwanted material
from engine oil then the oil pan holds
the engine oil the oil pump keeps oil
properly pressurized and flowing through
the engine so people say see Bill you
were wrong uh obviously this is an
explanation it's a bunch of descriptions
right well uh no it ain't okay people
confuse these things and so we need to
understand exactly what's going on here
this is a great example uh let's look at
that first sentence again uh uh motor
oil is used to lubricate moving parts
right right okay so the question is the
following what question does that serve
as an answer to okay what is the
question and the question is uh I'll
rephrase it okay uh why did John
lubricate the mo or use M Oil to U
lubricate moving parts and the answer is
yeah the oil was put in there to
lubricate the moving Parts you know so
so we're answering n a question of
physics we're answering a question of
philosophy we're answering a question
that involves uh not causes and
mechanisms we're answering a question
involves purposes and reasons and there
you have two on the bottom that I put
philos philosophically we can say uh
this um this is what we're trying to
answer John oil the parts so they would
move okay that's that's a question of
philosophy that's not a question of
physics it's why Ed John what was the
purpose right what what was the reason
that John did something and in physics
you would phrase the maybe in this sense
because you're trying to figure out a
why question involving causes and
mechanism you would say Parts move
because they are oiled okay that's an
issue of physics the other one is an
issue of philosophy and when you say
motor oil is used to lubricate moving
Parts you're rephrasing a philosophical
question and people confuse this as a
statement
a description involving uh you know in
this case oil okay it's not okay it's a
it's a theory that is phrased in a way
that it sounds like a description and
this is part of the problem you got to
keep in mind how it's phrased and what
question you are trying to answer with
the statement that you co consider a
description okay here's another case and
I showed this the other day we have um
we have this uh fellow here and his name
is cmir okay cmir is pulling on a donkey
that's what it seems like right but
we're not going to talk about the theory
here so we can't use the word pulling we
can't use the word pulling because if
you say pull you're already giving a
theory okay what we're looking at here
we're looking at description only okay
let's just talk about description what
can we describe well we can say uh and
we're assuming this is just standing
still well we have a donkey on one side
side and we have a rope tied around the
donkey's neck okay and we see this
fellow okay and uh what he's doing you
know we're going to call it a narrative
or narration what he's doing is moving
his hands along what appears to be a
rope or a cord or some elongated object
that's a description okay and now you
say well bill it's obvious that you know
what you're illustrating there is that
Casmir is pulling on the donkey that's
how the donkey went from A to B that's
how the donkey got closer to cim okay
well not so see I I have a different
Theory okay and I'm going to make
something else visible here so that you
can understand my theory okay and it's
air and I'm going to say look there's
this wind behind the donkey it's pushing
the donkey towards you know the
cmir so uh there's a different theory
for for for for this uh phenomenon that
just that you're staring at there
someone might say look Casmir is pulling
on the donkey and another person might
say no it's the wind pushing the uh
Donkey from behind in fact you have all
these people who talk about uh pushing
gravity you know uh and this is what
they're thinking about so again when you
use pull or push you're giving already a
theory that's not what you're supposed
to do when you describe okay so uh keep
that in mind
let me get rid of this one
here okay uh what if we had no rope okay
like we showed the other day so we see
this from afar maybe your eyesight is
not good so you can't see what the cmir
is doing there you're only seeing his
hands move you're seeing the donkey
comes closer we have no air or rope or
at least you can't see them and so the
question is now everybody's baffled
everybody says how did the donkey come
closer I don't see anything there and
only because you can't see you're
assuming there's no physical object an
acting on a donkey okay so this is the
issue the only issue here is that you
can't see you know subjective right you
can't see or touch maybe you know uh the
whatever is in contact with the donkey
which is the same thing that we have
when we let go of the pencil right you
can't see or uh touch the uh whatever is
pushing or pulling on this pencil and so
because of that you say oh gravity we
cannot explain we'll never be able to
explain it or someday we'll be able to
explain it in the future so you put you
kick the uh uh can down the
road so you you never explain it because
all you have to do is identify the
invisible object that coming contact
with a pencil and then it's kids stuff
then it's kids stuff then it's baby
stuff for kindergarteners 10-year-old
can understand it okay but unless you
put an object there unless you if you
just keep doing math you know equations
and measurement you're never going to
figure out the cause the mechanism that
underlies gravity and that's where we
stand today in 2,000 3,000 4,000 years
nobody has figured out how gravity Works
what the mechanism is of gravity and
they give you some irrationality such as
you know warp time you know and uh what
is that what kind of is that an
explanation to say that time is
bent what is it the seconds are bent the
minutes the
years okay yeah so all you have to do
for uh to explain you got to put the
rope in there and then you can give an
explanation doesn't mean people will
believe it just means that what's going
through your mind is this that you're
saying that the reason the donkey came
closer to uh Casmir your theory is that
he was pulling you know on a cord okay
so that's the theory okay then then you
can talk about pull because now you're
giving a
mechanism okay so this takes us to this
word object okay and this is what keeps
everybody from understanding people
think that an object is that which you
can see or touch and see and touch are
irrational criteria for the definition
of object you cannot use see or touch
and these are the reasons you can't see
air okay for example it's even though
it's made of atoms same as your chair
okay you can't see the Klingons table on
the other side of the universe now you
see the picture on the right you know
you can't see that because he's a
gazillion Lighty years away from you and
does that mean that that's not a table
that's not a chair that's not you know
there's nothing there and uh you say
well yeah I have the
potential as some of these what idiots
idiots whatever um that's that's what
they say they say look I have the
potential it has a potential to be
touched yeah but that means that until
you touch it it's not an object a table
is not an object the word table doesn't
refer to an object when you see it in
addiction and you see the word table
it's not an
object of course it is table is an
object everywhere in the universe in
every dictionary in the universe it's a
thing okay so so the question is you
can't say that because you can't see or
touch it using that criteria it's not an
object there are objects you cannot see
or touch and among them we include the
Rope okay so it's not a question of
seeing and touching and uh see and touch
also require an experiment and it
involves two
objects you need two objects you invoke
two objects to Define one the the word
object great uh and then the question is
is the asteroid not an object before it
strikes the
Moon is the moon not an object because
before the uh asteroid strikes it and so
you know uh are we we we can see these
two things out there we see the asteroid
coming towards the moon we say Well
they're not objects until they touch
each
other okay and uh yes see and touch are
subjective definitions because they
depend on the Observer you need you know
you need two objects you need one of
them to see and touch the other one so
you need an observer and that's why it's
a subjetive definition on the other hand
object that which has shape which is a
scientific definition of the word object
my greatest contribution the science by
the way uh not so much because I defined
it but because I found out how important
the word object is to science into
physics you know you can't do physics
without an object that's how simple it
is and um it's objective why because all
objects have shape if you can think of
an object that doesn't have shape please
let me know in the comments
section okay okay so here we move on and
we find out what why haven't they
figured any of this out well because
they never defined the word physics they
don't know what physics is they have
only irrational definitions for physics
uh mathematical physics and what's the
other one there
uh uh theoretical physics so we have
theoretical physics mathematical physics
and physics and they all mean the same
thing here's the the first one here's uh
physics says the natural science of
matter uhuh involving the study of
matter no no no no no study we don't
study in science okay anybody can study
even even baby study in in uh
kindergarten does that make them
scientists because they study so
studying is the wrong criteria the wrong
word to use to define any discipline out
there okay especially physics and
science okay and it's motion and
behavior through space and
time through time we travel in through
time how do you travel through time is
time a container and you travel through
it is it a tunnel what is time how do
you travel through time what does that
mean and the related entities of energy
and force energy and force belong to the
religion of math has nothing at all to
do with physics we do not use Concepts
we don't transfer energy we don't uh
push the force or pull it you know and
we don't use field we don't vibrate the
field because these are all Concepts
okay so none of that belongs to physics
we don't use word f words four-letter
words such as energy and field and mass
not in science okay physicist a
scientist who specializes in the field
of physics which encompasses the
interactions of matter and energy at all
length and time scales in a physical
Universe what's the scientist a person
who researches that's uh in Wikipedia
what's a physicist a person who does
research Colin's dictionary no no we
don't study we don't research we don't
do any of that stuff not not in physics
not in science okay anybody can do
research anybody can do can study and
learn absolutely nothing in fact not
even write a paper so so the guy studies
the guy did research
and we leave it there oh I did research
I'm a scientist no no uh study research
bad word
you know rational terms for definition
of disciplines in paleontology we don't
study in biology we don't do
research what we do is we explain when
you come to the conference people don't
ask did you do research did you
study yeah I studied for the test I got
a zero great you're a scientist because
you studied now you got to explain if
you don't explain it means you haven't
used the gr matter in your hair in your
head okay uh what does theoretical
physics say it says a branch of physics
a branch of physics you know the tree
it's got a tree branch that employs
mathematical models absolutely not well
maybe theoretical physics whatever that
is in science we only have physics no
theoretical physics and abstractions of
physical objects and systems to
rationalize explain and predict natural
phenomena explain you know math has no
hard to explain and predict you know
that's uh astrology palm reading you
know one of those and there you have it
mathematicians are like Mary Poppins you
know he had Mr Banks he was the banker
okay where she worked uh taking care of
his two kids and Mr bang stops her
because she did some boo boo with the
two kids and said will you be good
enough to explain all this Mar Poppin
says first of all I would like to make
one thing perfectly clear yes
I never explain anything and that
explains or describes mathematical
physics and theoretical physic they
never explain anything just like Mary
Poppins no
different okay and uh now we have the
last one which is mathematical physics
whatever that is mathematical physics
refers to the development blah blah blah
blah blah for such applications and for
the for formulation of physical theories
what's a theory an explanation math does
not explain we're done okay it's we're
done period pun punto no theories
explanations in math yeah there we have
no theories or explanations in math
physical or physical refers to objects
so if you don't have an object you're
not doing anything physical and math
never uses objects math replaces objects
with Concepts you know uh Point Mass
they take the whole elephant they weigh
them and say it's got a mass of I don't
know 5
tons and so they take the five tons put
it in a little Dot and say the the
elephant moved no no you mve the dot not
the elephant you want to move the
elephant you got to put the elephant
back and replace the dot with the
elephant then you can move the elephant
you can't say because you move the dot
that you know five tons
moved which is what they say okay so um
yeah mathare is not Yoda about uh
structure okay so here we have it uh my
definition uh this is the one we propose
for science science what is the
definition rational explanations very
simple okay and uh rational there's
several criteria for the word rational I
we usually Define the word irrational so
that's easier to understand you move
Concepts you don't Define your terms or
your your Define terms inconsistently
meaning you know you're you clean your
nose holes with your uh definition uh
the theory doesn't follow from the
hypothesis from the assumptions okay Etc
there's a couple more and so that's what
uh irrational is and explanations
explanation we just went over that it's
essentially the um
interpretations you know you're going to
explain something and that's called also
a theory
okay uh especially um you know
gravitational and electromagnetic
phenomena that's what we're interested
in why because those are invisible and
intangible see we figured out all the
tangible stuff it's the invisible
intangible stuff that we cannot answer
the mathematicians cannot answer why
because they never proposed
objects as
mediators and they say I can't see or
touch it and uh so that's when you have
to get the definition of object straight
that's why the definition of object is
so critical especially in physics you
can't do physics without the definition
of the word object okay so closing up
here math is a language okay it's
exclusively a
quantitive language math can only
describe math has no power to do
qualitative stuff okay yeah it's a
question of math cannot do lit it can
only do tit okay hope you got that math
cannot be used to provide physical
interpretations one branch of math deals
with measurement uh which is only
description right distance for example
meters time seconds weight kilogram
speed miles per hour Etc okay so that's
what we have those are just descriptions
that's all that math can do physics on
the other hand is exclusively
qualitative definition is rational
explanations of causes and
mechanisms okay we got got all that okay
so here we have another fell who asks a
question or makes a comment he says if a
tree falls in the forest and there is no
no one around to hear it sound will it
make a sound the answer is
no okay why because the most accurate
definition of sound accurate why do they
talk about accuracy what's accuracy have
to do with anything it's either rational
or irrational and this one's irrational
what he's going to say here so we don't
have to worry too much about it but
let's have a laugh here definition of
sound is not that sound is waves in the
air but rather is relationship between
the vibration of the air and the eardrum
uhuh rear faction and compression right
if there is no ear drum there will be no
sound okay good luck convincing a de
person who does not have an eardrum that
sound uh vibrates while it doesn't even
have access to test well he doesn't even
have access to test the sound my God
poor fellow I guess he studied at the
monastery as well okay so here it is
what we do in science we kill the
Observer there are no observers in
science or in physics we have to kill
The Observers no Witnesses are allowed
and this fellow thinks everything's
about what the person heard and so here
we have a a de person next to you and
you can hear the sound the other guy
cannot hear the sound
so his answer is well there is no sound
because the death person cannot hear
it and so yeah he he doesn't have the
slightest clue about anything where this
guy studied maybe at a monastery who
knows anyways let's set them straight
sound is what the forest makes okay the
tree falls makes
noise that noise is called sound
vibration already of the air uh that
surrounds us right now what you're
that's objective you know that's a
objective definition of sound sound is
what something means the vibrations in
the air right now whether you can hear
it or not that's that's a question of
you know uh otherwise you know there
would be no sound in the universe
because uh you know we can't hear all
the sounds that are in uh in China and
they can't hear all the sounds we have
over here and so I guess there's no
sound in the in the universe because
nobody can hear what the other guy has
because he's too far away okay is that
your logic so no sound is what the tree
made when it fell whether you can hear
it or not whether uh you know whether
your friend can hear or not is
irrelevant whether the de person can
hear or not isn't irrelevant okay that's
an observer
related uh notion definition and of
course it's irrational because you're
putting in observer there are no
observers in science especially for no
definition we do not use observers in
any definition as soon as you do it
becomes subjective and it means it's
your opinion against mine that's why we
never put observers or Witnesses or
whatever you want to call them in
science
okay okay uh give me a second
here okay so
U we have another F and he says the
following says the I think it's the same
F but I'm not sure now the definition of
the existence of a thing is a
relationship between the existing thing
and the Observer again we introduced The
Observer right these people are want to
introduce subjectivity in everything
they say look it depends on what the
Observer measured what he heard what he
saw you know again they introduce the
Observer because they think in terms in
subjective terms they're doing more
psychology and Psychiatry than they are
doing physics the universe is merely a
product of the mind oh is it so when I
die the universe dies because it's the
product of my mind right there's no
Universe for you everybody has his own
Universe right in his mind is that what
it is merely product of mind because
there is no Universe without someone
saying that the Universe exists well the
universe cannot exist because the word
universe is a concept and Concepts
cannot exist in science specifically in
physics okay it has to be an object the
universe is not an object universe is a
concept that means atoms or matter if
you want to say it matter and space
that's the universe two things even
though space is not a thing but it's
treated as a thing in in the definition
of the word Universe suppose that there
is something in the universe that is
impossible for any Observer to observe
yeah exactly what if you don't observe
it and so he says no one can even
observe its effect or monitor any
information blah blah blah it is
isolated from the rest of existence okay
great but it still exists okay depending
on what you mean by exists have you
defined the word exist of course not
because you nobody has in the last
10,000 years I had to be the first
person to define the word exist because
nobody thought that it was so important
among them atheists theists and
agnostics who go around in circles
talking about whether God exists or
whether God doesn't exist and they never
Define the word exist nobody has any
idea what the word exist means you look
at the dictionary all you find the
synonyms you know being and uh and
reality and just synonyms we don't have
any idea what the word exist is until
now now we know what the word exist
means we have a rational definition
exists has to be an object that has
location okay if it has a location it's
got an object has location it exists by
definition not because I say so okay you
don't have to agree to the definition
again you have a better Mouse
strap show us or keep your trap
shut and says okay for us there is no no
difference between the existence and the
non-existence of this
thing well again you have to Define
exist is it an object yes then it's got
a chance of existing does it have
location yes now it exists if it has no
location it doesn't exist if it if it's
not even an object it certainly doesn't
exist see how simple it was very simple
no observers necessary no no provision
for observers in the definition of exist
for us there is no difference right in
this case existence and existence have
the same definition yeah that's his
conclusion because he never defined the
word
exist okay so uh what do we say to him
well again here it
is
H the mafia principle we kill the
Observer no observers in science first
of all and no observers in the
definition of exist okay so keep that in
mind uh exist simply means an object
that has location if it meets those two
criteria you know like if God meets if
God is an object has location with
respect to all atoms in the universe
then God exists by definition okay so if
that's your proposal that's your
assumption that God is a physical object
has location hey you've already made God
exist for the atheist for the theist and
for the agnostic for all of them all
these religious people okay here's uh um
fellow who says the following there
needs to be a mediator for Gravity
otherwise it's nothing but magic like
quantum entanglement yeah so what do you
propose I mean draw it I need to see an
image of it I need to see what object
you propose and the question is whether
that object pulls or pushes because
those are the only two possibilities
right for Gravity either you push maybe
with particles right or you pull with
some elongated object I would think
right but maybe you have a different ver
verion different Theory no problem you
know put it put put it forth draw your
thingy whatever it is the mediator and
tell us whether it pushes or pulls very
simple
stuff okay and another fellow finally
says the following says uh if you
release a pencil it falls to the ground
but if you release a balloon with helium
it rises to the higher part of the
atmosphere he was talking about uh
gravity right and yeah then the question
here is it's no different than stating
why you don't fall through the floor I
mean why don't you go through the floor
why do you float in water or why does a
balloon float in or your rubber ducky
why do they float in water and why don't
they go through the floor and uh you
know you can say it's density you can
say that the atoms also say the ground
or the table or whatever are uh rigid
you know and that's why things don't go
through them easily right maybe a bomb
does density is the antidote to gravity
okay you have all these people called
Flat earthers another ideats or idiots
or whatever you want to call them okay
they believe that density is what causes
gravity okay great whatever density is
okay so if the moon were covered in
water you wouldn't be able to fall at
one six the gravity on Earth as it is
now can a pebble fall through the ground
floor why not tell me why not okay is
that density or what is it can a drop of
water sink in the center of the Earth uh
to the Center of the Earth you know I
mean you have the ocean why doesn't uh
why doesn't those Drops Fall all the way
to the Center of the Earth okay so you
got to tell me that you know density is
it is that the ground is too hard for
them what's the reason here are they all
pulled by gravity towards the center of
the earth and there you have the two
scenarios okay the one on the right is
the normal one where you have air and
you let go of a piece of metal and
a feather there and it falls very slowly
because you know you have air it's going
through the air uh and air offers some
resistance to the feather while it
doesn't for the uh piece of metal there
and on the left uh you see there they
took all the air out and you can see
they all fall straight down like if you
know gravity pulls on both of them no
density there okay so uh you got to
explain that and here's um here's
another uh version of that
let me show it to you Ryan Cox he went
to this place and here it is let's see
from the again he dropped
this and uh this is under vacuum it took
the air out or most of it and you can
see that the feather and the ball fall
at the same time whereas when uh it's uh
you know it's not under vacuum here
you'll see when it's not under vacuum
you'll see what happens normal stuff the
ball Falls immediately and the feather
takes a long time to come down okay and
here you'll see one more time the two
falling at the same time because of
they're under
vacuum okay so yeah uh you get to answer
gravity and hopefully it's not this
nonsense that the flat earther called
density whatever that is okay uh again
density is a concept and uh they don't
understand that we need a physical
object we want you to tell me what comes
in contact with a feather or the ball or
whatever or the metal piece there why
don't they go upwards that's what I want
to know you know why isn't the density
on the upper side you know we have air
covering the Earth right that's why we
can breathe so why doesn't the feather
go upwards you know all the way out of
the out of the Earth all the way out of
the solar system that's what we want to
know please tell us that's that's where
you that's where you would use your
brain a little bit so far you
haven't okay and um F says will you ever
use your theory to do any real world
predictions applications aha wouldn't it
be cool project uh cool project to use
your rope model to build a working GPS
receiver well what's the answer to this
gentlemen uh the answer is um you know
we do science here we don't do
technology okay and what he's asking is
is there any practical use for the
theory involving the Rope which which we
call thread Theory by the way uh and the
answer is no science has no practical
use whatsoever people confuse physics
with um technology or science with
technology and what do I mean by that uh
well you have um uh people who say that
GPS proves general relativity correct
and that uh computers prove Quantum
correct that uh there are true theories
what do you what do you mean by that
what do you mean uh the computer proves
that Quantum is correct does does does a
computer the fact that we have computers
this technology does it prove that a
particle can be at two places at once is
that what it proves does GPS prove that
time is a physical object that you can
bend it which is what the conclusion of
these people is so the question is does
technology prove a theory and the answer
is absolutely not technology has Absolut
absolutely nothing to do with physics
okay with science and we have to
separate those two things people have
this in in their minds oh look all the
technology we have today we wouldn't
have it if if all the mathematicians
were wrong mathematicians have nothing
to do with the technology we have today
all technology all technology is
developed by trial and error or like uh
um Thomas Edison said you know I haven't
um uh what was it the I Haven failed he
said I just discovered 10,000 ways that
don't
work he kept trying one thing after
another did he know what electricity was
did he have to know electricity did he
need to know any math no all he needed
to do was try one thing after another
until he got it right he said he tried
one filament he tried another one
finally got it right and said this is
the filament and he made it cheap and
available to everybody and then they
came with other filaments later on
tungsten and so on this is trial and
error say nothing to do with physics
with explanation so yeah the Rope model
uh if if it helps you in any way think
in uh in a different direction for
developing some technology well more
power to you that's not the intention
okay uh physics and science have nothing
at all what's to do with uh with
technology okay so these are two
different you could say
disciplines you can take that to the
bank okay let's get on with time travel
what the world what in the world is time
travel well again we have to begin with
our um with our definition let's define
this one more time we defined it several
times in several videos but let's do it
one more time what the hell there it is
idiot or
idiot you can pronounce it any way you
want want okay individual with big ideas
that's what an idiot is and it comes
from the uh old clling on meaning big
idea we have little ideas normal ideas
and then we have big IDs okay and yeah
and so who are the people who have big
Ideas well most of them are called
special relativists okay and they have
these weird Big Ideas where they say
that time can be bent time can be bent
can be War warped you know and they say
that length can be stretched simply
because a particle travels very fast you
know it
stretches uh I'm sorry it shrinks it it
lengths contraction they shrink they
shrink uh the the ruler or whatever
you're carrying right and um the mass
increases it gets heavier and heavier
and heavier and what is mass mass is the
quantity of matter and so are we patting
it with more matter is that what we're
doing you know that's why it's becoming
fatter well I don't know how can it
shrink let contraction at the same time
become bigger like you know more mass so
you know you figure it out but that's
why we call them idiots or ideats right
because they have big
Ideas okay so we have to settle that
because we're going to have a lot of Big
Ideas right now you know so be prepared
okay one of the things they talk about
one of the biggest ideas they have is
time travel they say that you can travel
to the past or to the Future to the
future is guarantee they already know
that it's proven there's no discussion
uh to the past there is still some
debate you know a lot of people say well
I don't know if that's true others say
yeah mathematics prove it maybe it's
within the laws of
probability um you know science allows
for it or physics allows for it the
equations allow for it okay so they have
all this stuff so what are you talking
about well they're talking about this
they're saying you know here you are in
the modern world over there on the right
computers and so on You Walk Through The
Time Tunnel or rush through it at the
speed of light or whatever right and you
end up I don't know in the 16th century
you he started out with a watch maybe a
wrist watch or or a what is it a timer
of some kind and you end up with what a
sand clock an
hourglass okay so yeah this is this is
the notion that they have they call it
science you say B well that sence not
science that's not part of physics it's
uh philosophy of physics philosophy of
science maybe what was it natural
philosophy someone said uh no here it is
look I'll I'll prove it to you proof
proof evidence okay here we have it and
here it is uh this is you just put um
time travel on Google you just Google it
I got 7 Million results for um uh
scientific papers that's what I put in
there okay now I don't I didn't take the
trouble to look at the 7 million believe
me uh I just took a first page there a
few of them and you can see that it's
quite an popular subject okay in the
archive there where people put their uh
papers before they publish them right
and you can see the dates there on some
of them and even to this day people talk
about this nonsense called time travel
so yeah what we're talking about here is
that uh uh people actually write about
this in the in the what what they call
the scientific literature okay so uh and
the question is who writes about this
stuff uh do it does it involve
philosophers of physics or natural
philosophers or philosophers of science
no it's mathematical physics physicists
who write about this and try to publish
their papers it's theoretical physicist
it's what they call physicist who do all
this kind of work so here we you know
when you put a put them against the wall
and you call her Bluff they say well
that's philosophy of physics well if
it's philosophy of physics and that's
not part of your job description is not
part of your line of work why in the
world are you giving me a physical
interpretation when you have no
Authority no expertise to do
so okay so it's it's only when you call
their Bluff when people real when
intelligent people confront them and say
you're you're talking nonsense they say
well that's philosophy anyway that's
when they dismiss it and who are are the
people who are writing all this nonsense
the so-called physicists theoretical
physicist mathematical physicist and so
uh here we have uh a summary from Siam
okay Scientific American is time travel
possible okay and this came out in 2023
so you can see it's a very uh
contemporary subject okay scientists
don't relegate time travel to the
crackpot realm okay they only relate to
the crackpot realm you know the Rope
model maybe some others right that goes
into the crackpot real because they
decide what's crackpot but this is not
crackpot uhuh in fact the laws of
physics might allow chronological hoppy
laws of physics what laws who dictates
these laws is it the people in Cambridge
or or is it the U pastors at Harvard you
know science began to take time travel
seriously in the 1980s time traveling to
the near future is easy aha if a person
were to hang out near the edge of a
black hole only a few hours might pass
for them while a thousand years went by
for someone on Earth if that person who
was near the black hole returned to this
planet they would have effectively
traveled to the Future that is a real
effect that is completely
uncontroversial it's a done deal they
proved it you can't challenge it anymore
going backward in time gets thorny uhuh
uh scientists have come up with a few
ways it might be possible so they
haven't uh you know they still haven't
let go of this okay it's still there
um um might be possible a closed timel
curve describes the trajectory of a
hypothetical Observer that while always
traveling forward in time whatever that
means means how do you travel forward in
time is it a tunnel you know what are
you doing there from their own
perspective at some point find
themselves at the same place and time
where they started creating a loop well
it depends on how many beers he drank I
mean maybe he thinks at the same place
where he started I mean how can he end
up in the same place if he went forward
in time or backward in time or whatever
right and uh said this is possible in a
region of SpaceTime that war by gravity
Loops to into itself absolute poock all
this why does time travel depend on
exotic matter it is needed to hold open
a wormhole a tunnel in SpaceTime
predicted by general relativity
predicted that connects one point in the
cosmos to
another so uh you can see time travel is
still alive and well and we're going to
make sure that it dies a sudden death
today okay let's make sure with that and
yeah here you see Brian Green he's going
into that time tunnel okay he's going to
the past and here he is he comes up to
where he was early in the morning
shaking hands with himself he jumps into
The Time Tunnel or Wormhole whatever
that is uh doesn't look like Zero
Dimensional or onedimensional it looks
like threedimensional to me uh and I
don't know what it's doing there in the
middle of the uh airport but yeah he
does this jumps in there and he ends up
with himself in the morning okay shakes
hands with himself now is this science
or what okay and uh we're going to
debunk this nonsense today and again
we're not gonna debunk doesn't mean
we're going to here we're going to
convince you we're not interested in
convincing you or persuading you or
recruiting you we're going to show the
irrationality of what they're talking
about okay that's what we're going to
show okay so debunking here means we
objectively show that it's irrational
what what's irrational well when you
move uh
a concept when you um have definitions
that are inconsistent or you use them
inconsistently right and the theory
doesn't follow the explanation doesn't
follow from the
assumptions okay and here we have
another fellow and his name is Neil
degrass Tyson what does good old Tyson
have to say about time travel you're
going to have to read here okay so uh
here it goes I made it go as slow as
possible so it allows you to read so pay
attention here it
goes
okay so the only reason they rejected
time travel to the past they accepted to
the future but they the reason they have
a problem with that in the past is that
you can kill your grandfather your
father and mother or whatever and then
you won't be born and so they say well
that sounds like a little contradiction
of course it's a contradic and idiocy so
why are they even considering this
nonsense in published papers
by physicists okay that's what you got
to that's got to be worrisome you know
here you're paying all these people
indirectly sometimes through government
uh taxes Etc and they go to these people
and you're paying for all that
indirectly anyways and these people are
looking at time travel and they call it
science or they publish it as scientific
papers and then when you call their
Bluff they say well it's only philosophy
and it turns out no philosophy is no
philosophers is uh writing papers on
that it's all so-called physicist
mathematical physicist theoretical
physicist so that's what you got to look
at there we have a contradiction there
okay and uh so how do we start this
thing well the criticism of this thing
okay uh time travel well we we're going
to present this uh this is our Universal
movie it's a tool that we use to uh
challenge uh ridiculous theories from
idiots you know ideats or whatever and
what we're showing there is that in a
single frame of the universal movie it's
a 3D movie it's the one God runs I guess
uh we have only uh uh the this movie
that's moving uh from one location to
the next every atom in the universe is
there in a single frame and every atom
in the universe only has distance with
respect to each other and it's moving to
a a different location it's moving from
location to location but a different
location means you're in a different
frame of the movie okay so that's the
notion we have here in a single frame
all you have is static Concepts okay
such as object distance location and
existence these are examples right there
are others like standing sitting those
are also um static concept they're not
Dynamic okay uh on the other hand on the
bottom there you have uh you require at
these two frames for any of those you
need uh two frames to uh talk about
motion position plasma ether field
energy time and so many others okay so
we're looking at a single frame a single
frame only has static Concepts such as
ESP location that's what we want to
focus on today location okay so
hopefully we got that what we're showing
with this um U Universal movie we're
only talking about objects they have uh
specifically atoms right and every atom
in the universe is in that frame and
they all have a certain distance with
respect to each other and we call that
location okay the set of distances from
all atoms to one atom in the universe
the gazillions gazillions gazillions of
atoms to one atom we call that location
the location of that atom with respect
to all the other matter in the universe
that's location in physics okay location
is not you know so much on the x axis so
much on the y axis we don't care about
that nonsense location is physical it's
just a separation from one atom to all
the other atoms in the universe some
very close by and the other ones very
far away okay that's our starting point
I hope you understand what the purpose
of that um the universal movie is about
okay so here we have uh the Christian
version of um creation right and so we
have a single frame there which is Adam
and Eve on the earth okay so God creates
the the earth I guess in uh you know he
was moving over the waters started
creating piece by piece and the question
is for any of those films we want to
know how he went from frame one to frame
two where he suddenly creates man you
know from nothing or creates the first
bit of matter from nothing so how did he
go from frame the one frame on the left
to the frame in the middle that's what
we want to understand what is the
mechanism what is the cause how did he
do this in his garage right you want to
know the mechanism and of course there's
no uh intermediate frame because we're
taking the next immediate frame in in a
universal movie so there's no
intermediate frame that means uh there
can't be a mechanism we already have the
contradiction in in in that image right
there because we go from something from
nothing to something with no time
okay okay so that's the starting point
for Christianity not very good uh uh you
know what God really does it really
creates the the universe eventually I
guess and here you have a dynamic
version of that and you say Bill why did
you put it in a single frame well we put
it in a single frame because that's how
the mathematicians see this they say
that all that time time involves motion
and it's Dynamic but they say the
universe you know the the entire uh
shebang the entire Universe the entire
SpaceTime which is what you're staring
at there is in a single frame the past
and the present coexist together with
the future it's all in a single frame in
fact let's stop that so that you can see
what I'm referring to that's what they
propose okay they propose that um you
know that there's a single frame and we
have all the time in there we have the
past present and the future all in that
block which they call the uh block
Universe SpaceTime whatever ever you
know and that's why they can get away
with saying that if you're in the
present you can travel to the Past
because it coexists with a present so
you can go each one of those slices
there by the way that's time slices of
of every you know what we call the the
single frame but see they put all those
slices which are different times they
put it all in a single frame of the
movie because they talk about the block
Universe coexistent at the same time you
know past present and future Future Okay
so let's get that straight what they're
proposing okay so uh the only other
thing that they do is they get rid of
God poor old God they get rid of him and
they have only you know the black
Universe there you know but the the
question we want to understand is uh the
first two frame not the frame gazillion
there we want the first frame and the
second frame they go back in time what
they say and they say they go to frame
number two and they start with a
singularity and and so the question is
how did we go from nothing to the
singularity how did that Singularity get
there whatever that Singularity is we
don't care uh it's got to be an object
because that object gave uh origin to
all of matter so we just want to know
how we went from frame one to frame two
that's what they need to explain and of
course they say that frame one is
unscientific uh that it's irrational to
ask that question because they cannot
verify through an experiment or who
knows
what how that came to be yeah of course
not that's the only thing that they have
to explain they have to explain how it
was possible for the singularity to come
into being okay until they can answer
that they have not understood absolutely
anything okay or they cannot explain
anything okay so um what are they saying
and here's a here's the key Point okay
listen to this okay here we have um
uh under under the universal movie right
we have all the atoms in the universe
we're only going to look at five of them
and these five move with respect to all
matter in the universe okay and so we
only draw these five atoms and you can
see that they're moving across the
screen okay and remember what we're
going to do we're going to go from 457
we're going to take one of those atoms
and we're going to take it to frame
number
454 because that's what they say when
they travel into the past we can also do
in Reverse take an atom from 454 and
take it to
457 what's the problem with this well
let me show you what the problem is the
problem is that these people are not
saying that anything moves in the
universe what they're saying is that
every time that you that the atoms moved
to a new location they in fact did not
move to that new location what they did
was they created new
atoms they made copies of those atoms
okay because the only way you can move
to to find an atom in the past if only
if that atom is still there okay that
means we're going to duplicate all these
atoms and here it is this is what's
happening according to them they're
creating copies of the atoms every time
they move along okay so they're making
new atoms new matter in the universe as
you move a long time there is no motion
there is only a creation of matter okay
and here um let me show you a
little uh picture okay uh look at this
carefully I just want you to see what
they're trying to do here okay here it
goes
okay so this is what we see we're saying
that the guy on the left there can go
visit the guy on the right only because
we have all these frames still in
existence otherwise you know how can you
go back and see the guy on the far right
there you can only see his hat there uh
cap um yeah the only way you can see him
if he still exists there that's the only
way you can shake hands with him and
that means all these frames exist
simultaneously that means we created new
matter this guy never moved what what he
did was we created new matter we create
a new person for every one of these
shots that depicted
him okay so we're creating new matter
according to the idiots of uh math okay
the that's what they concluded so there
is no motion okay what we have is
creation of new matter every time you
think you move okay so let's start with
this we're going to show this this is
our Universal movie okay and just at
random we pulled some frames out of
there right and this is the universe as
you can see there in each one of those
frames you have all the atoms in the
universe
okay and
um Okay so what do we propose well we
propose uh that all that matter there uh
is really a single thread okay that
weaves all that matter atoms and the uh
ropes that interconnect them okay so
this is what we're proposing that's
different from mathematical physics
mathematical physics proposes discrete
particles that's what they've always
done we call it ether that's what
mathematical physics has always had they
just gave it different names SpaceTime
false vacuum they're talking about The
Ether they're talking about particles
why because a particle is not a particle
a particle has become a number a value
and what they do they move these values
and they talk about the value that they
move and that's what they're going to
put in an equation they have no use for
dots for particles so the particle has
stop being a particle a core pusle you
know the classical one and what we
propose is that all atoms in the
universe are physically interconnected
and there we try to show as best we can
that the atoms are connected okay so
that's the difference with mathematical
physics the fundamental difference okay
and what comes out of this well we have
this oh give me a second
here we have
this the one on the right has become a
single thread we're saying that a single
thread
underlies all of matter
okay and um math is Remains the Same
nothing changed there okay and why what
does this thread do well this thread
weaves around and
constructs um what we call all the atoms
and ropes that interconnect them and
here it is this is uh how we visualize
all this we're saying that the thread
turns into these two electric and
magnetic thread that serve as connectors
physical connections between atoms the
atom is made of the same threads okay
that's why there's a single thread in
the entire universe that weaves all
atoms and ropes that interconnect them
okay and this is more or less what an
atom looks like according to us that's a
2d version of it okay and um and here we
have
um the our atom looks more or less like
that the 3D version on the right and the
2D version on the left and what you're
doing what they're doing is Quantum
Jumping by going back and forth the
electron shell or membrane balloon
whatever you want to call it expands and
contracts at Great velocity what it does
is by doing so it torqux the rope and
that's why light travels always at the
constant speed it only exchanges uh
frequency for wavelength and vice versa
okay and so there's your Quantum jump
that's our atom that's our model okay so
the point here is that we are proposing
that um there's a single thread in the
entire universe that weaves all matter
so if we were to dismember every atom
and every rope in the universe we would
end up with a single thread and that's
different than what mathematical physics
has always proposed and alicant they all
propose particles discrete particles
they try to do with discret particles
push pull the whole works that's why
they cannot explain pull because they've
always done it with discrete particles
and you cannot pull with rocks and
that's why they never figure it out
unless they change their assumptions
okay okay so this is uh the universe uh
now we're going to untangle all matter
okay we're going to disassemble all the
atoms in the universe and we're going to
have the thread there okay that's that's
what you see there but according to the
Rope model you know uh matter cannot be
at two places at the same time like in
mathematical physics and so what happens
uh all these frames that you see there
are really
inexistent this is uh the only one
that's there here let me show it to you
and it's the uh the one we're going to
call the present frame number 457 okay
all the others are imaginary in other
words they're in our brains they don't
exist in reality okay so there's only a
single frame and that contains all the
matter in the universe right it's like
God froze the entire universe right
every bit of matter nothing moves
there's only Frozen Universe static and
we're going to disassemble that and
there you see it that's all you would
see so um let's erase all these other
frames that's all we have really that's
reality the present okay and uh I like
to put it this way father Universe you
know he only exists in the present he
doesn't live across time or through time
or whatever they call it he doesn't have
motion okay father Universe does not
understand motion father Universe only
has
location okay
I hope that you're understanding okay
doesn't mean you believe in it doesn't
mean you accept it uh just want you to
concede it now so that you can
understand the theory founded upon it
that's the way we do science okay so
we're going to concede the Assumption
just for the sake of argument and here
it is we're going to have um you and
there's you with a little atom that's on
your shoulder we're going to look at
that little atom the red one there in
frame number
457 okay but remember we're going to
erase all the films all the other frames
I'm sorry okay uh because they don't
exist okay so uh all frames before
457 are in your head they're no they no
longer exist they happen they're no
longer there in other words all those
locations of
atoms uh that disappeared we have a new
location which is at frame 457 of every
atom in the universe and one of them is
the one that you have on your shoulder
so this is the correct way of depicting
that all the others do not exist the
only one that exists is the one frame
that we just froze and we'll call that
the present so far so good okay and uh
here we're going to look at we're going
to try to move that atom to the Past
okay that's what we're going to try to
do so here it is but we're going to move
it to a frame that doesn't exist
okay because that frame frame 154 really
doesn't exist but that's what these
people claim that they can do that they
can take an atom you know that's part of
your body when you travel so we're just
going to look at one atom and we're
going to say hey we're going to make
that atom travel through time and it's
going to go to a frame that no longer
exists okay because there's only so much
matter in the universe we're not
creating matter every second as
mathematical physics claims it does
because it says it can travel to an
existing you in the past or an existing
Napoleon or an existing Caesar or
whatever okay so that means Caesar's
didn't die he's just in a different uh
cross-section of time you can still find
him there shake hands with him that
means he's still there
okay uh so this is important to
understand you know what we're talking
about here okay okay so here we have uh
we're going to assume now that that
frame exists okay let's assume it exists
because that's the Assumption they make
that in reality uh the frame when you
were in the past anytime in the past
still is there and you can go see
yourself okay that's that's what they're
saying okay so we're going to assume
that it exists so that means we're going
to look at that same atom in your
shoulder a few days ago you know for
example that atom is still there in both
frames it didn't disappear you know we
replace our atoms in our body every so
often you know you probably have a
dinosaur atom now or an atom that
belonged to a dinosaur somewhere in your
body you ate something that used to
belong to a dinosaur you know that could
have happened but in a few days we're
going to say that that atom was still in
your shoulder okay and so we're going to
try to take the one in your shoulder at
457 we're going to take it to frame
154 before we do uh we got to show you
this because we're going to replace you
really with every atom in the universe
meaning the thread that winds every atom
in the universe this is what we really
have and there's your atom okay it's
part of the uh thread of the universe
okay the single thread as we call it
that the closed loop thread that makes
up all matter in the universe okay I
hope you follow through and what are you
trying to do well this is what you're
trying to do you're trying to not only
send it to an inexistent frame but
you're dragging the entire uh thread
from our universe to that other frame
where you have that other Universe over
there which is same universe as ours so
you're you're distorting completely our
thread when you do something like that
you know you're you're pulling on every
atom in the universe when you go through
time to a different frame okay to an
inexistent frame really okay so this is
what these people are saying that you
can do and of course under the thread
model uh the Rope model you know you
can't you can't do that it's uh totally
irrational what these people are
proposing and again let's understand
understand what we're saying here we're
saying that in order for you to visit
yourself yesterday that means that for
every second for every
microsc gazillions of a second every
frame in the film we made a new U every
atom in your body you know instead of
moving to that frame what they did they
created A New U and that other the
original U was still there and he
created all these 's you know you have
all these 's that's the only way that
you can explain what they're trying to
do which is to visit yourself and shake
hands with yourself in the past or in
the future because this this applies to
the Future as well it's just as much
nonsense to say you can go to the Future
as you can go to the past and even they
say well it's for only for a little
while even for a little while you can't
go to there's no such frame there for
you to land on there better not be
otherwise you've drank too much beer you
know you got to take it easy with a beer
okay what are conclusions well here are
the conclusion
father Universe only exists in the
present he's always in the present what
is the present location distance from
atom to atom in the universe there's
separation between every atom in the
universe and the only thing that we want
to add to this is that we say that
there's a single thread that weaves all
these atoms in the universe but it still
doesn't take away from the fact that
father Universe only exists in the
present father Universe does not live
He's not alive
and he doesn't move through time or he
doesn't move at all father in Universe
always wakes up looks at himself says
okay every atom is where it should be
right now they all have distance with
respect to each other every atom has
location each one is an an object all in
a static single frame of the universal
movie then he goes back to sleep for an
eternity again right and then he wakes
up and again says okay
every Adam has location I'm okay then
and so he always lives in the present or
exists in the present as long as you
keep the wording correctly then you're
going to make sense but as long as you
don't Define your terms like they do in
mathematics you'll never understand
anything with that I'll see you next
week bye-bye